how long is this flight 10 hours and 15
minutes
you just want to make sure you don't
think you John Cusack's in this country
you definitely don't want to have any
Christopher Reaper you want to leave
your bud Bundy ago Singapore is not the
place to hit the rock duck boss
Darrell's in no Arnold Schwarzenegger
Zinn I don't even have a Harlem shake
honestly sir we're not Portland
Trailblazers
you went half done that's not gonna Tom
Green but I'm sure I'm just glad I don't
have any chronic cage search value I'm
not gonna find any Herbie Hancock don't
even ask for any dude and growth yeah
super core man thanks bro we just had
more fun going through customs then
probably anybody ever had a border
tomorrow night hey thanks man you too
what's that building with the boat on it
you want some durian fruit he's like you
stupid white boy right here we go I'm
gonna go big
Oh
that's good for me dude what are we
doing right now just walking Phoenix all
over Singapore yeah that's a dead baby
for sure excuse me is that a dead baby
it's dead baby
my opening act just kicked [ __ ] ass
his name's Orion now a Ryan hit me with
Australian well tanley now it's really
nice to be able to be the opening act
for the guy he does jackass you know
it's really nice all right American well
man I love jackass it's really great you
know with all the stunts and all that
stuff going on okay
British so you know it was really great
to see the fact that you were born in
Britain you know that's okay Scottish I
thought it in a way but how the hell did
you get when you stapled your balls to
you okay French really really loved the
ballet actual doing the ones Oh Swan
Lake oh my god okay Spanish where's no
of course it is very important for you
to make okay Italian ladies and
gentlemen you do this at home
it showed the selfies on a selfie Easter
selfie each of the selfie what do people
think about that tattoo right there ah
there you go that's the ticket
age or the selfies are the selfie
I knew this Daniel day-lewis would come
yeah that's exactly what's gonna have
we're in Hong Kong and this is what the
Yahoo home page looks like
we're head my beautiful children wait
you're not gonna [ __ ] believe what's
happened since I got home that's why you
need to subscribe here and you look like
I could really use some [ __ ] Steve oh
[ __ ]
autograph books hats shirts get them
right there and if you're only getting
to these videos for the first time Holly
[ __ ] get back and watch the ones before